these days everyone's talking about we
work this fall we work scrapped a
planned IPO and ran dangerously short on
cash the office space startup turned to
Softbank for a rescue deal that saw its
valuation once as high as 47 billion
dollars fall to under 8 billion now
attention has turned to the venture
capital fund that helped pump up weworks
valuation and fund it's superfast growth
the vision fund started in 2017 by the
Japanese telecom conglomerate Softbank
has raised a lot of money to pump up
high-profile startups like we work how
much money a hundred billion dollars the
vision fund has rewritten the rules of
venture investing and driven up the
valuation of tech startups but that
strategy of showering money on promising
young companies failed with we work and
it's starting to show cracks in other
investments as well
[Music]
the vision phone is unique among venture
capital funds for a few reasons venture
funds typically look for startups with
strong growth potential but because
these investments are high-risk
high-reward funds tend to be
conservative they raise small amounts of
money and they write small checks to
entrepreneurs that's not the case with
the vision phone in 2018 all US venture
capital firms combined raised about 55
billion dollars the vision funds 100
billion dollar war chest is nearly twice
as large it has spent it quickly
investing about a billion dollars a week
in its first year here's a breakdown of
where all this money came from
Softbank chipped in twenty five billion
dollars itself another 60 billion
dollars came from the sovereign wealth
funds of Saudi Arabia and Abu Dhabi the
rest came from corporate partners like
Apple and electronics manufacturer
Foxconn about 40 billion dollars of the
fund was raised in the form of a loan
with an annual interest rate of 7%
borrowing is an unusual way for a
venture capital fund to raise money
because they're investing in unproven
companies that put pressure on the
vision fund to start making money
quickly the vision fund currently has
investments in 88 companies according to
a spokesman we Worth is among the funds
largest many of its other investments
are burning cash and have it laid out
clear paths to turning a profit three of
them are ride-hailing services which are
locked in brutal price wars the funds
investment strategy centers on giving
startups a lot of cash to grow quickly
the goal is to help a company corner its
market and then go public allowing the
vision fund to cash out the sizable
return the fund has invested at a
furious pace the hundred billion dollars
was meant to last four years but is
nearly gone after just two but it hasn't
yet cashed out of most of its
investments and of the companies that
have gone public some have
underperformed the vision funds stake in
publicly traded Buber is now worth less
than what the fun paid to invest and its
profits on slack have been declining
since the messaging app company went
public for the still private companies
in its portfolio the vision fund has at
times saddled these startups with more
cash than they asked for dog-walking
startup wag was seeking 75 million
dollars in funding before the vision
fund persuaded it to take
hundred million dollars the investment
was to help the startup defeat its rival
Rover but wags growth stalled while
Rover sales continued to increase
now wag is trying to sell itself likely
at a price below the six hundred and
fifty million dollar valuation of the
vision funds investment in late 2018 the
vision phone made a big bet unfair a
startup that leases cars to consumers as
well as to ride Hale drivers but former
employees said the company expanded and
offered promotions that made car leases
unprofitable fair CEO resigned in
October after the company laid off 40%
of its workforce fair's board
temporarily installed a vision fund
partner in his place Softbank also
installed one of its executives Marcelo
Claure a as executive chairman of lis
work after the startup CEO Adam Newman
was pushed out
Softbank also sank another six and a
half billion dollars into we work to
stabilize the company Softbank CEO
Masayoshi Son took the blame for the
wework debacle when he announced in
November that the fund had an operating
loss of nearly nine billion dollars for
its most recent quarter despite the
funds short track record Softbank is
trying to raise a second vision fund the
vision funds arrival cost a tectonic
shift in the speed and scale of startup
investing but it remains to be seen
whether they can consistently find
winners in Silicon Valley
you